GILBERT STRANG: OK.
So this is a video in which we
go for second-order equations,
constant coefficients.
We look for the
impulse response,
the key function in
this whole business,
and the step response, too.
So those are the responses.
So I'm going to call g--
that will be the impulse
response, where the
right-hand side is
a delta function, an impulse,
a sudden force at the moment t
equals 0.
So that's the equation.
That's the impulse.
And g is the response, and
we want a formula for it.
Then the other possibility,
very interesting possibility,
is when the right-hand
side is a step function.
And then we want the
response to that function.
I click a switch.
The machine starts
working, and it
approaches a steady response.
The solution rises from 0.
So it starts at r of 0
equals r prime of 0 equals 0.
The step response
starts from rest.
The action happens when I
click a switch at t equals 0,
and then r of t will
rise to a constant.
Very, very important solutions.
But we'll focus
especially on this one.
OK.
So that's our equation with
the right-hand side delta.
And of course, that
right-hand side
is not totally familiar,
not as nice as e to the st.
But there is something
that-- there is another way
to approach it-- that's
a key idea here--
that gives us this all-important
function from solving
a null equation.
How's that?
I start with a null
equation, but now this
had no initial condition.
So this one started from g
of 0 and g prime of 0 both 0.
And everything happened,
boom, from the delta function.
This is the same function.
Except when I look to
see what happens at t
equals 0, what happens is g
prime immediately jumps to 1.
So another way I can approach
g, the computation of g,
is to think of it-- I'm just
looking for a null solution.
I'm looking for the null
solution that starts from 0.
But it starts with an initial
derivative, slope equal 1.
So I know that g
is a combination.
So I know how to solve equations
like that, null equation.
You remember s1 and s2?
I look at s squared-- I've
made this coefficient 1-- so s
squared plus Bs plus C equals 0.
That gives us s1 and s2.
And now I'll tell
you what the g is.
So that gives us the s1 and
the s2 in the null solution,
and we're looking
for a null solution.
So our g of t is
some combination of e
to the s1t and e to the s2t.
OK?
It's some combination of those.
And we want it to be 0.
So no surprise, if I subtract
those-- I'm starting at t
equals 0.
I'm starting--
this is 1 minus 1.
It's 0.
And now I just have to
fix the initial slope,
the first derivative, to be 1.
Well, what's the
derivative of this?
This brings down an s1.
This brings down an s2.
At t equals 0, I'm
getting an s1 minus s2.
So I'll just divide
by that, s1 minus s2.
There you go.
That's the impulse
response-- a null solution
that satisfies these
special initial conditions.
So that's the function
in mathematics
that's sometimes called
the fundamental solution.
It's a solution from which
you can create all solutions.
It's really the
mother of solutions
to this second-order
differential equation.
Because if I have
another forcing function,
this tells me that growth rate.
It's just like e to the at
for a first-order equation.
Remember the growth
rate e to the
at for the simple first-order
equation with interest
rate coefficient a?
Now we have two.
Instead of a, we
have an s1 and an s2,
and that's the special function.
OK.
We need to get more insight
on that for particular cases.
So let me show you
the same function when
I have no damping.
Start with that case,
always the easiest case.
When B is 0-- B was the
damping coefficient,
the first derivative in
our differential equation.
Can I just bring down the
differential equation?
When B is 0 here,
that's no damping.
I just have the second
derivative and the function.
That's when things
oscillate forever.
So that's what will happen.
With B equals 0, I
have pure oscillation.
The s1 and s2 are cosines
and sines that oscillate.
Or it's neater to stay
with exponentials, the i
omega and minus i
omega, where that's
omega n, the natural frequency.
Now, if I just plug in that
s1 and s2-- the plus is s1
and the minus is s2--
I plug it in there,
I get a nice formula for g of t.
So that's what g of t
looks like for no damping.
It just oscillates.
OK.
The next case is underdamping.
It's good to see all
these cases each time.
So that's a small value
of B. Underdamping
means there is some
damping, but it's
small enough so there's
now a real part,
but there's still
an imaginary part.
So this is, in a way, the trick
is the case when s is complex.
If I go higher with the
dampening, increase B further,
then I'll hit a
point where there
are two real solutions equal.
And if I push B beyond
that, I've got overdamping,
and those two real
solutions separate.
They're different,
but they're real.
And then my formula,
in that case,
overdamping, that would
be the best formula.
But with underdamping, I
can see the oscillation.
If I just plug in those two
solutions for s1 and s2,
you'll see that I have the
e to the minus B over 2t
appears throughout.
But then I have the sine
of omega over omega,
same as I had before, except
now the damping frequency
is a bit slower than
the natural frequency.
Damping slows that
frequency down.
And in a different
video, we had a formula
for omega damping,
omega damping.
And then increase the damping
some more, then this part--
this omega damping goes to 0.
We don't see any imaginary
part in the solution.
We see two equal real values.
They're simple.
They have to be just minus B/2.
So that's a case of two
s's coming together.
And when two things
come together,
we're used to seeing
a factor t appear.
So I have that they came
together at minus B/2.
So I have the
exponential of that.
But I have a factor t
from the merge of the two.
And then if B increases beyond
that, that's my formula.
The two s's are real.
I don't think one
memorizes all this.
I had to look them up and
write them on the board
before starting this video.
But I hope you see that
they're extremely nice.
The no-damping case
with [? pure ?]
frequencies and the underdamping
case with a real-- a decay.
The critical damping when
you increase B further,
you just have that
and no oscillation.
And then beyond
that is overdamping.
OK.
So we're good for
the impulse response.
And now I just have to say,
what's the step response?
So can I end this video by
going back to my equation?
I have to bring the board
down to show it to you.
So now I'm going to deal
with the step response.
So the equation is the same.
I'm calling the
solution r for response.
And the point is, the
right-hand side is now
a step instead of a delta.
So we'd like to solve that
equation starting from rest.
So a switch went on, and I
want a formula for r of t.
That's all that remains.
And actually,
that's just-- well,
you can see what the
particular solution is.
We look at a
particular solution.
Well, this right-hand side is 1.
This right-hand side
is 1 beyond t equals 0.
So I'm looking for a way
to get 1 out of that.
Well, or it can be
just a constant.
The particular solution
is the steady state
that we're approaching.
And there's one little
cool thing to do.
Sometimes people who have the
dimensions and units of things
clearly in their mind
will put a C in there.
This is really the good thing
to do is to have that C in there
because now the units
for r are the same as-- r
is going to go to the 1.
The steady state will
be 1 now because I
have Cr equals C times 1.
And out in infinity, the
simple solution is r equal 1.
If when r is 1, its
derivative is 0.
Second derivative's 0.
r equal 1 is a solution.
It's a particular solution.
It's the steady-state solution.
Good.
But that r of t equal 1
does not start correctly.
We want to start at
0, with a slope of 0.
So I have to subtract off one
of these particular solutions
with e to the s1.
And now I have to
get it so that I
have to subtract it off so
that this thing starts from 0.
Let me see if I can do it.
I think maybe if I
do an s2 e to the s1t
and subtract off
an s1 e to the s2t.
Do you see what that
one has achieved?
At t equals 0, I have--
well, at least at t equals 0,
I've made the derivative
0 because the derivative
will bring down an s1 there.
That derivative will
bring down an s2.
And when I put t equals 0,
I get s1, s2 minus s1, s2.
Good, good, good.
OK.
Now I think that together
they're all correct.
I need to divide by s1 minus s2.
Let me just say,
I think that's it.
It wouldn't be a bad
idea if I just checked.
And having checked, I've
learned that that's a plus sign.
OK.
So the graph of r.
This is a graph of r of t.
It starts from 0,
and it rises to 1.
Asymptotically it's 1.
This is a graph of r of t.
And in practice, that's
a very important number.
What is the rise time?
How far do you have to go in
time before it rises up to,
let's say, 95% of 1?
All these questions are
extremely practical questions
for an engineer.
What's the rise time?
And you're playing
with this formula.
So let me just make
another comment
on this r of t step response.
My other comment is
I've emphasized g of t,
the impulse response is like
responsible for everything.
It's always with us.
And how are those connected?
That's my final
question in this video.
How is r of t
connected to g of t?
Well, let me ask about
the right-hand sides.
How is the step
function connected
to the delta function?
Answer, the step function is the
integral of the delta function.
The integral of
the delta function
is 0 as long as
you're integrating off
where the delta function is 0.
But as soon as you
pass the big spike,
then the integral jumps to 1,
and you have a step function.
So the step function is the
integral of the delta function.
So the step response is the
integral of the delta response.
It's the integral of
the impulse response.
r is the integral of g.
r is the integral of g with
the correct initial conditions
that gave us this and eventually
[INAUDIBLE] approach 1.
So that is the two key
solutions, you could say.
The impulse response important
in theory and in practice.
The step response extremely
important in practice
because turning on
a switch is so basic
an operation in engineering.
Good.
Thank you.